artificial intelligence once again
distorting the line between reality and
what is fake Elvis is coming back to
life as an AI holograph 47 years after
the king left the building and
tragically died a UK company announcing
that it is prepping a a holograph AI
concert special entitled Elvis Evolution
it features a life-sized digitally
recreated Avatar of Elvis and is slated
to debut in London this November the CEO
giving this preview of what to expect
you'll see Elvis perform in front of you
for the very first time in London
actually um and you'll see this unique
performance uh uh generated by
AI I mean sign sign us up judge would
you go in a minute in a minute I love
Elvis Presley look but the but the whole
thing I mean the issue really is that
now ai is going to create entertainment
what they're going to look to do is
eliminate the middle guy who's a talent
I mean you think about how much money
Taylor Swift makes right she's at a
billion dollars um they can create a
talent that someone that everyone would
like and get a song on the on the radio
or stream it or whatever and they then
can make a fortune it's about power and
money and greed and then they they've
got robots that are doing our jobs all
right and then social media is
eliminating interpersonal communication
people don't talk on the phone anymore I
mean it's almost like like at some point
they're going to eliminate humans I mean
this could really really Jesse bring him
back to life I wish he did come back to
life because I'd take Greg Gutfeld to
his concert with me and show him what
the king really does Greg slandered the
king the other day in the commercial
break so I came prepared with some facts
oh great did you know who the greatest
selling artist of all time was it's the
Beatles number two Elvis Presley over a
billion albums three Grammys 31 movies
because he was an actor on the side
spent the most time on the Billboard
charts than anybody number two Frank
Sinatra close second the guy is a living
legend Greg how dare you I I would
demand a retraction okay um how do we
know Elvis wasn't already a hologram I
mean do we have have you guys ever met
Elvis I can't wait for the Hologram
groupies like what kind of Rider does a
hologram get in the first me case I was
I was assaulted by a hologram look the
problem here is he's dead so the only
benefactor are people not doing the
actual work you're freeloading relatives
this is why I'm licensing my likeness
now so hologram Greg can perform while
I'm alive and I can reap the deserved
benefits because what's the point of
having a hologram five because they will
do that once we're all dead just so
Jesse's kids can get another boat I'm
not paying for your
I should do multiple Holograms so I
could be on tour all over the country
that's what it's for this is not for
dead people this is for us so we can
we're greedy little freaks Jessica um
two things one is kind of like a sad
thing to say about this but why I think
this kind of innovation is good the
first part of this I like that at least
these are Live Events you know how we
talk about how we're consumed by being
on our phones all the time but if you
can go to a concert right people are
going to go and see the performances is
what happened would you was the first
big hologram but they're just going to
go like this the whole time yeah that
part is annoying I do like it now I've
been to a couple comedy shows at Masson
Square Garden that they take away the
phones now and they put them in that
little pouch the second thing that I
want to say which is a little bit sad
but I think it's a cool side of all of
this is now a lot of doctors are
recommending if someone is going to pass
away that they do all these recordings
so you can have their voice when they're
gone or create Holograms anyway my mom
can scold me from the the grave I'm sure
she'd love to um really hard to remarry
though as a widower you know when you
still have when you just sit there with
the Hologram yeah oh yeah she's still
here she's still here you said you
wouldn't
Remar I think that's cool though yeah oh
dear um we can't fear it we got to
embrace it right it's change is coming
for sure hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else